- Joe Rogan threatens to
sue CNN for defamation
on their claims that he
was taking horse dewormer.
Well, not exactly, he was
just simply grousing about
what he claimed was unfair
reporting by Jim Acosta,
claiming that Joe Rogan
had taken horse dewormer.
It is in fact true
that Joe Rogan took Ivermectin
after he contracted COVID-19,
but he got a prescription from his doctor
and took the human variation of the drug.
Now, it doesn't actually
look like he's gonna sue,
but let's assume that he was,
would he have a case for defamation?
Well, probably not.
First of all, as a celebrity
he'd have a very hard time
against Acosta and CNN,
because he'd be subject to
the actual malice standard,
which requires basically
that Jim Acosta know
that what he was saying was false.
On top of that, Acosta cost of might have
the defense of substantial truth,
because Ivermectin in
variations is used for
both horses and people.
And then of course, there is the defense
of hyperbole and opinion, your
opinion on revealed facts,
because Acosta was
intending to insult Rogan,
because Rogan like an idiot
refused to get vaccinated
so he had to get treatment after the fact
for his COVID infection.
So was it sloppy reporting? Yes.
Is it defamatory? No.
Are we going to see these
people in court? Sadly not.